should we obey the Bible word for word
find out on this episode of LED live
[Music]
what's up everybody thank you for
joining us again at LED live as you can
see we have a little bit of a different
set we're still in the workings on our
new new set this is a sneak peek of half
the new set so we got a black background
the new set's gonna have a really cool
background so we're going to talk about
a topic today actually a friend of mine
sent me a video from Logan Paul you guys
know that I've heard of them I don't
know who he is is he a Christian
no he he's known for his Antics and he's
kind of been in the spotlight for doing
controversial things and stuff like that
but he's a very famous YouTuber very
famous Britney doesn't know about him
but very famous millions of views
millions of subscribers and uh
apparently has at least two friends that
are Christian and he had him on the show
and so the topic of this video is
actually called should we obey the Bible
word for word and it's just a six minute
video but what I thought was interesting
was
what these guys are talking about
because they're talking about things
that I don't really hear Christians
talking about much is this something he
produced or is this something that
someone ripped off the internet no this
is on his show impulsive wow so he had
them as guest on his show
and it's funny like when you when you
hear some of the stuff because as he's
talking about the Bible you'll hear The
Two Hosts are kind of like they try to
crack a joke and kind of Dodge the thing
and they're like yeah you know when
people are uncomfortable they they like
to joke and stuff like that like they're
calling them out on like the Bible makes
you uncomfortable yeah so let's just get
right into it let's check it out George
what's up with that interpretation of
the Bible uh like what like that's
that's one of that right that's one of
the things about the Bible that it
confuses me bro you didn't read the
Bible well because what if I interpreted
it like that how can there bro that's
just about interpretation you know
what's in the Bible be careful of wolves
that are Skies as sheep
there's a lot of priests which one am I
a sheep you know what I'm saying there's
there's evil everywhere bro if I was the
devil I would do two things one make you
not believe in me because then if I you
don't believe in me you don't believe in
God and then two
I'll make you think I'm God
and then you'd worship me in your own
way you know what humans want to do they
want to take their lifestyle and put it
on a higher power and be like Oh My
God's okay with it I want multiple wives
that come with multiple wives there's so
many things that people want and they
change their beliefs if you want it
really bad you could have it whatever
like in the Bible like you know a lot of
people what they do is they like try to
fit into their lifestyle so that's what
you get the misconceptions where it's
like contradictions it's like well
so-and-so says that but then so-so says
that but then he's just like okay but
when you get down to the nitty-gritty of
it if you take out your own personal
like you know wants of the world and
stuff like that and read it for what it
is it's the most simplistic book ever it
tells you how to live and stuff like
that like in the like I used to love
shrimp and love pork and stuff like that
but in the Bible in Leviticus it says
not to eat shrimp and pork not shrimp
not shrimp but if then when you realize
about it it's not just like saying don't
eat it then when you do the like
research shrimp there's would you eat a
cockroach no
the shrimp is the Cockroach of the sea
they're literally the most nastiest
creatures but high in protein Bottom
Feeders behind proteins why uh does it
actually say Don't eat shrimp and pork
they don't eat uh animals uh without
fins and you only eat uh fish with fins
and scales what do you guys think about
this so far wow wow that's kind of
surprising yeah right this is this is
this is really weird because I from what
I mean what do you think about this I've
heard I've heard it said that in ax you
know God gave everyone everyone all
animals
okay
and um
let's pull that up because I thought
it'd be interesting to kind of cover
that topic because uh I mean that's
that's one of the primary arguments in
the Bible it said the Bible says I can
eat any animal look all these animals
came down snakes elephants reindeer I
don't know right what I think is cool is
he's he's coming right out and saying
look Christians they try to manipulate
the Bible to fit their lifestyle and say
well my God's cool with it I got
multiple wives or whatever and he's
addressing that Christians don't really
obey the Bible the way they should
they're twisting scripture and things
like that and and so far I mean what
he's saying is a controversial what I
believe is a truth I'm ready for you
know Keith's exegesis yeah of the text
but one thing I will say is that it's
unfortunate it's such a danger when we
insert our own beliefs or biases into
the text or just in general
misunderstanding a text
removes
um the blessing that's within the text
or the truth that's in the text that can
be applied in a way if it's applied in a
way that it should be would lead us into
truth right
okay so this comes from Acts chapter 10.
okay so Cornelius
the Bible says there was a man named
ancestoria called Cornelius a centurion
of what was called the Italian regiment
so he's a centurion and he's a Roman
he's not a Jew but it says he's a devout
man and one who feared God with all his
household okay and he gave alms to the
people he prayed to God always
yeah he's a Roman but he's obviously
seeking seeking yeah so
basically what happens is he saw a
vision of an Angel
and and said to him Cornelius you know
and he's like you know what is it Lord
is it your prayers and alms have come up
before Memorial before God now send them
into japa and send first Simon whose
name is Peter so he knows he needs to
get a hold of this guy named Simon Peter
and he's told where he can find him
where he's staying
so that's pretty handy right so then
Peter says the next day they're on their
way
their journey into the city Peter goes
on top of the house it's the sixth hour
he was really hungry
yeah he wanted to eat
and the text says while they were made
ready he fell into a trance and saw
heaven open an object like a great sheet
bound at Four Corners descending upon
him to let him down to the Earth and in
it were all kinds of four-footed animals
of the earth wild beasts creeping things
birds of the air The Voice came to him
rise Peter kill and eat but then he
decides to argue with God
Peter said not so Lord for I've never
eaten anything on or common or unclean
Boyce spoke to him again the second time
what God has cleansed you must not call
unclean so it was done three times the
object was taken up into heaven again so
here he is he's presented with his
vision
right does Peter understand what's going
on what's this it says something right
after that right
like so yeah in verse 17 it says well
Peter wandered within himself what this
Vision which he had seen meant so he
didn't know he's not entirely clear he's
wondering because to him it's like okay
I now have two pieces of information I
have to reconcile my entire life I have
been taught
do not eat these things and now I have
this voice from Heaven that says kill
and eat these things I have known that I
should never eat
and he's wondering probably a lot of
things like should I really eat them
doesn't mean something else does God
contradict something that you know is
taught before what's going on
so
after that
I want to interject before you get the
punchline so what I think is interesting
is it says that Peter didn't understand
it so to me a lot of people use this as
we can eat whatever we want but I'm like
but why would that been so hard for
Peter to figure out if literally it was
just like you told me it was obvious
yeah and and another thing is is
he's on this mission that God has it's
like we're seeing this story like this
Centurion you're supposed to meet Peter
and they're coming together and all of a
sudden in the middle Jesus is like
oh by the way you can eat anything you
want go ahead it's like it doesn't even
make sense with the storyline like oh
remember when you're I've seen you on
this Mission I just want to tell you by
the way you can eat anything you want
but go ahead and Jesus is so consistent
he came to enlarge the story not to
contradict so Peter's default would
never be oh this is going to contradict
to that I'm gonna do it anyway like it
has to be something at least something
defense for that to happen right also
everything that God gave was symbolic I
I haven't yet to see a vision that
wasn't be striving out of the ocean
seven you know cow skinny cows eating
fat cows bowing wheat bowing down to
wheat stars all of it all of it was
symbolic there was not one that's just
like outright like this is how it is so
Peter probably knows that and he's like
what does the vision mean so the story
picks up and cornelius's servants show
up they're looking for Peter
and you know he's asking him
you know why have you come here they
tell him the story of what happened with
Cornelius
and
um the next day Peter goes with them to
meet Cornelius
um let's see
and so in this meeting
Peter has like this speech that he gives
says but this is starting in verse 26
but Peter lifted him up saying stand up
I myself am also a man and as he talked
with him he went in and found many who
had come together then he said to them
you know how unlawful it is for a Jewish
man to keep company with or to go to one
of another Nation
that God has shown me so this is now
we're gonna
become clear what God showed him or what
God was revealing the vision this is how
he interpreted yeah
um
uh
uh here we go God has shown me that I
should not call any man common or
unclean therefore I came without
objection as soon as I was sent for I
asked then for what reason have you sent
for me and then they go on after that
and you know he's meeting with them and
giving them the gospel and praying with
them and you know they receive the Holy
Spirit and and it doesn't say anything
about food yeah so why is there such
confusion in the Christian world when
they're like nope the sheet was let down
he was told he could eat anything yet
the next chapter right if this is the
same chapter same chapter says
I had a vision that I should not call
any man not food unclean and then when
he said that you'd think God would be
like oh no no you got it wrong it was
about food no Peter got understood and
the tie-in is is verse 14 where he says
not Peter said no not so Lord for I have
never eaten anything that is coming
unclean so the unclean and the unclean
word is in both those verses so it's
obvious he is talking about the vision
here he says I have seen and it's
talking about unclean things that are
there in the vision yeah it makes it
obvious to me that this is not this is
not about food this is about whether or
not you're going to preach to All
Nations now
I guess another piece to that is you
know you have these levitical Health
laws that they're alluding to in this
video
and and saying that they use Health laws
apply Beyond just the time of the Jews
you know man's digestive system hasn't
changed God knows how we operate and
that has stayed consistent
but what he was dealing with that that I
guess cognitive dissonance you know that
he's dealing with
is that the Jews thought that their
message Their Blessings everything that
they received was for themselves but
from the very beginning God never said
that right his his message consistently
all the way back is that it was for
everybody go to the ends of the Earth
with all the nations salvation was for
everyone we were supposed to be a priest
of all Nations so we were supposed to be
teaching these people so God raised up a
small group of people to go out and
preach his word to everybody we got the
where they got it wrong was I think
Psalms 1 1 where it says you know don't
don't uh well let's look that up real
quick so we got to analyze that so they
know exactly what there's a man who
walks not in the Council of the young
guy yes that's the way of centers nor
sits in the seat of the scornful but his
Delight is in the law of the Lord and
they kept thinking oh well we shouldn't
be uh we shouldn't be uh going and
talking to those Sinners we shouldn't be
sitting in the seat of the scoring but
we should be doing that but that's not
what that meant so it's all a
misunderstanding and and that's that's
an easy
I mean I guess it's an easy trap to fall
into lots of people have
misunderstandings or can interpret
things the wrong way
I think if you look at a broad
perspective of History where the Jews
were at
they basically went from realizing our
nation has continually apostasized we
have not done what God has written and
asked us to do
and because of that we've suffered for
it you know we've been in captivity and
so you might say they went from the left
to the right right and so then they made
all these rules and regulations that God
didn't have in place to keep them from
going back the other direction to
protect their people but then it became
that those rules
became their religion yeah and that
became more important than the things
that God had asked them to do
and so you know now we're
you know several hundred years later
still kind of arguing and Christendom
about the same things let's say I think
that's the the common trap for all
Christians today is this pendulum swing
it's extremism the whole thing about the
Bible is balance this is the way you go
but people are like no it's all law you
got to keep it or they're like no it's
hyper Grace it doesn't matter what we do
God forgives it all and we just need to
find that perfect balance because the
Bible says faith without works is dead
Jesus said you'll know them by their
fruits you're going to know a Christian
by
who they are they're demeanor their
character is not because of what they
claim to be it's the things they they
desire to do just like when you are with
a if you married if you're in a
relationship with another man a woman
hopefully you're not a man and a man
that's not what we're talking about here
but if you are in that loving
relationship whether it be with your
family your parents your your husband
your wife your
um you will want to do stuff for them
yeah like maybe you want to go get
flowers for your wife right you're not
doing that to win her love right that's
works but just to judge someone and say
that oh you are a works-based uh
religion or you are a Works based uh
person you're basically trying to read
their mind because you can't tell if
they are by mentally you can't tell if
they're trying to do something because
they're trying to win love or you're
trying they're doing something because
they love the person so much right it's
impossible to know that and so that's I
find it fascinating and it's a little
bit of a
when people say oh yeah your Works how
do you know that right how do you know
I'm giving flowers to my wife because
I'm trying to uh win her love with works
or how do you how do you know that I
love her right yeah you can ask most
Christians why do you not murder people
why do you not steal and they'll say
because
you know I love God I love people
because that's what the law is you know
it's love God love your neighbor and
they say that's all of it but if you
love God which of his Commandments will
you disobey you prove to God you love
him by OB by obeying him because you
trust him when you know how much he
loves you and you know that he's not
withholding anything good from him from
you and you trust that then you're just
like you said it Lord I'm gonna do it I
trust you you brought up the digestive
system hasn't changed like the Bible is
being backed up by science because
when you have some kind of heart
condition or any a lot of conditions you
go to the doctor the first thing you're
going to do is say cut out red meat or
something and the the Navy actually did
a probably spent millions of dollars
trying to figure this out because that's
how the government does but they spend
all this money on testing what can our
soldiers eat if they get abandoned on
abandoned island or something a stranded
Island and after all this study and they
said basically in the end if it's got
skins and fails skins fins and scales is
safe to eat and that was their
conclusion it's like well that was in
the Bible for free it's interesting that
they started to go that direction too he
wasn't like is it this isn't just in the
Bible he's like if you look these things
up you'll see that they're not good for
you and there's a multitude of
scientific
literature-based evidence to suggest
that a Whole Foods plant-based diet is
the healthiest diet for a human being
you can get everything that you need
from it and there's multiple
documentaries that have been made one of
the more recent ones I've watched was
Game Changers were really yeah really
well done you know who some of the
producers on that were Arnold
Schwarzenegger or James Cameron you know
they're backing this and saying yeah I
mean Arnold big muscles yeah even
Clinton has gone over too because they
said there's problems with you you need
to help your health why don't you switch
over to uh isn't it funny we wait till
we're damaged and the doctor says you
need to eat like this or like okay but
when the Christian says look the Bible
says this don't put me under the law
I'll eat what I want we're going back to
the comment Brad made about the Minds
The Bible has been accused of like a
closed-minded book but really reading
the Bible demands an open mind
and so listening to this conversation
when uh the Christian gentleman said
would you eat cockroaches no
so uh shrimp are the Cockroaches of the
sea they're scavengers and Logan Paul's
response is like oh but you know it's
good protein it's like wait wait so
having that open mind that God has
provided other actually better options
protein is not just found in shrimp like
you can let that go you know what's
funny protein this is this is a known
fact protein is not ever produced by an
organism protein is only produced by
plants that's right that's right we get
it second hand from it yeah yeah you get
the protein from the cow because the cow
eats grass all day long like
okay I have a scallop does that fins and
scales no then no no Lobster I can't
have them no you know what's crazy about
Lobster back in the 1800s and stuff like
that jail thing yeah
I didn't even know that but I knew it
was considered like a poor food yeah it
was it's a great Lobster you were looked
at as like damn this dude is down it'll
be like slaves and uh prisoners yeah I
was just reading about that the other
day but it's delicious
to where it's like oh if you eat lobster
you're high class where do you where do
you draw the line on like
what things and this is not judgmental
whatsoever but like where do you draw
the line like what things are okay to
disobey from the Bible and what things
aren't like for example it says don't
eat shrimp and pork but I'm sure there's
something in the Bible that says like
don't go hang out with strippers and
make videos about the only or like don't
have sex before marriage do you know
what I'm saying how do you pick and
choose like which things you are gonna
do and which things you aren't gonna do
it's not a pick and choose thing it's
just me disobeying like I'm just got it
I'm not gonna sit up here and be like
okay whatever this is just like let me
just straight up disobeying like dead
ass I I have to live with that and I
need to fix that with myself and stuff
but I'm not going to be that type of
person because you know what people want
to do is they want to like
they'll be like okay well you see here
to make it seem like it's okay but I'm
never gonna do that I'm never gonna do
that and me even saying this doesn't
just be saying like me accepting that
fact doesn't make it right sure but I'm
just not gonna be a hypocrite
all right
yeah for a Christian to just say look
that's wrong in my life and I need to
work on that and fix that instead of
being like no we've been together a long
time and you know God knows we love each
other God sees that we're married inside
all right dude how many times have you
heard people like twit try to twist what
God has clearly said
two shall become one flesh and a
marriage and stay together forever till
death do us part but yet people shack up
all the time and that's what a lot of
people like in the homosexual community
and stuff they they feel offended that
Christians point the finger at them all
the time but it's like oh but you know
these two are shacked up yeah and isn't
that against the Bible too and I say
yeah that's wrong too you know right
fornication and that's why I always go
out of my way to say look we're not
focusing on this one thing we're calling
Sin Sin all of us sin watching these
terrible things about adultery and
Witchcraft and all that is just as much
sin so I think the one thing that's
that's probably difficult depending on
who's watching this is
you know it could be easy to look at
this group and say you know we're
sitting on our high horse and and being
the judgmental group in reality
everybody's working on something right
in their life and I think the whole
point of this discussion is are we going
to be honest with ourselves and with God
and say yes I'm a work in progress there
are things in my life that I know that
are not right but the Bible is still the
standard that I that I live by and
measure up to and I'm
I'm either going to obey that or not and
if I if I don't am I going to try to put
myself higher than the Bible
and you know I like to describe it like
everybody's on a on a Continuum on a
variety of things so some people have
problem with anger or jealousy or
they're weak in their prayer life or
they just can't hardly get to Bible
study or whatever it is and then other
parts of their life they're stronger on
and I think what the holy spirit is
trying to do is bring everybody to the
same place yeah you know and
it's it's more healthy to support each
other in that instead of pointing the
finger and saying well you got a problem
with you know whatever that's that's you
know I'm not saying don't call Sin Sin
right but we all have things that we're
working on and what we like to do as
human beings is make one thing the more
important thing than anything else which
I think is why God has to go out of his
way to say all sin is equal don't be
calling his sin out take the log out of
your own eye before you start picking
out the spec in someone else's eye so I
have a question and maybe this is off
topic but um you know how as Christians
we don't believe in
um cohabitating before marriage is there
a scripture verse that clearly says that
or is that just something we've
insinuated because of what that can lead
to well it says fornication is wrong I
mean
I don't know if there's a scripture
about that are you saying like male and
female roommates to split bills and
separate rooms and all that that
yeah I don't know that there is a
specific verse that says exactly but the
Bible often isn't like that there's no
specific Bible verse about you shouldn't
smoke a cigarette I was gonna say
there's all kinds of non-specific verses
but there are verses that say like you
should avoid the appearance of evil and
you know things like that so
and also not to put yourself in the way
of Temptation
um so that kind of thing falls under
where it can and lead to is it possible
for two people to live in the same house
be opposite sex be friends and be
attracted to each other be attracted to
each other and do nothing
yeah it's totally possible possible not
unlikely though right
but you would have to be very strong
committed people and have some you know
boundaries and and dare I say you'd
probably want a a third party really
checking in on you to make sure that you
hold to those boundaries because it's
very easy people when they hang out with
each other spend time with each other
they grow closer to each other you know
in friendship and then and then beyond
another way to look at it is the Bible
is actually
um very specific on its instructions or
like the way it should be done
uh you leave your father and your mother
and you cleave unto your wife so if if a
structure is given sticks to the
structure instead of looking for a okay
or something outside of the structure
um about let's say you have a couple who
has the who have has divorced and then
um one of them gets
like
engaged or remarried or something like
that but before they actually get
married to them they're thinking oh the
rules don't apply to me because I'm not
young anymore I've already been through
this process before is that same process
still expected to not cohabitate to not
sleep together until you're married or
is that just something like oh no that's
just for younger people yeah because
there's no age in the text it's just
blanket once you're in marriage in
general yeah so so I I think that's an
interesting question because it leans
more towards is this a rule that we keep
as if we are keeping a certain amount of
steps or is this a rule that is helping
us live a better life you know because
if if we are if we think about it as a
process if you commit to someone before
you tie your emotions into them which is
essentially what fornication does you
tie your emotions into that person and
then they break up with you you're gonna
be devastated right I mean it's just
gonna wreck you for weeks and months
even years sometimes it just ruins
people and so if if you if you do that
whether you're young or whether you're
old
it's the same thing and so God
essentially is saying hey look I'm
putting these rules out for you because
this is how your psychology works this
is how I created your brain to work this
way so that you are meshed with one
person that you want to love for the
rest of your life not because he wants
to make us follow rules and he wants to
put his finger on us just because and to
that point I know we're only halfway
through this video but I expected his
question it's something that comes up a
lot in conversations
it's like what do you band what do you
not obey and I think it's because well I
don't know if the conversation started
that way but the video started off with
them just talking about what they can't
do or what they're obeying not
necessarily why they're obeying it or
why they're acting a certain way and
when we read the Bible God always
emphasizes the why where he starts off
with the why especially you see that in
creation before he starts giving
instruction and obedience is an
expression of our love to God and
um just being mindful of that as
Christians going on having these
conversations can hopefully
even if that question does come up I
think it will come up less likely like
oh well what do you obey when people are
set the right foundation at the
beginning of the conversation yeah the
other thing is God is really good about
setting principles
um if you look at the Ten Commandments
it's really a bunch of principles and
that's in Exodus 20. a lot of
Exodus after that not all of it but a
lot of Exodus after that is expounding
upon those principles in detail to help
people understand what he meant by that
um because people are people and they
would do the same thing that you know
everybody else does and they start erase
Rising questions about well what about
this situation what about this situation
and so God kind of spelled out some of
those situations for them and said okay
if this happens this is what you do this
is the principle applied but still we go
with you know
it's because we're broken simple human
beings and and sinful and always trying
to find out our way around the system
and I think God did that he really
didn't need more than the principle if
we were completely sold out I like that
you bring that up because it's really
like love God love your neighbor it's
like what does that look like these ten
what does that look like these 600 or
whatever you know it's like yeah like
you said just really having to spell it
out my my thing on it is this and I've
kind of came to this scenario like this
year and a little bit of last year uh
I've kind of played with this wisdom
comes from God so when I get angry or
impatient or I sin it's because I just
don't know what the circumstances is and
I don't know how to act on it so there's
a lot of things that I still am doing
that's a lot I'm very sinful bro I sin
all the time it's because I'm ignorant
and I don't know that's why I'm spending
my nights reading the Bible and trying
to catch up on my education on how do I
turn away from the sin so now it's it's
not hard I like for example before this
is a story I really didn't mention to
people but before I found Bell which
every guy here is always asking me why
are you not marrying her I was celibate
for eight months because I met a guy who
goes oh when are you going to get
married in fact the way that you were
stopped I had the same thing
uh you were saying thank you uh I met a
guy and he goes why why would God give
you the most perfect girl if you treat
every girl now like garbage you treat
him like trash and I sat there for a
second I was like all right I always
think that I'm his son but when I meet a
girl I don't treat her like it's his
daughter so now and remember there was a
girl that you brought over I'm not going
to mention her name but she does adult
films and she was doing drugs and
everybody was doing their own thing and
I came up to her and I said hey like you
don't have to do that and uh I have
these conversations with girls now
because I have the wisdom to be like yo
this girl's doing this or this guy's
doing this because they're lost they're
hard and nobody wants to talk to them
about it eight months of me treating
women with the ultimate respect in every
single class of women uh I found the
most amazing girl in my life so it takes
it takes discipline because you're the
sin's Never Gonna Move it's still gonna
be there but then you're going to start
seeing it from a different perspective
and now you're gonna be like oh I don't
want to play with that anymore do you
consider yourself a son of God
yeah of course do you consider Bell a
daughter of God I know you're going with
this is that incest
oh my God I knew he was gonna do that
that I've seen that that actually came
up in our Channel comments before I mean
I I think the the term incest has become
a negative term because of how genetics
plays with ancestral relationships in
the beginning you have to think about
this Adam and Eve's daughters and sons
there was nobody else that they could
marry and up and during that time the
genetic pool was so great right that
hey I mean it it worked right now incest
is bad primarily because of the physics
the the the Medical Practice behind it
our genetics can't work together and it
just has it's just weird
that kind of a slippery slope and even
if there were all these details that you
could present I think
just to dispel this because I also think
he's trying to derail the conversation
because that guy just dropped the bomb
and it's something that should be
considered that's what I was saying I
wasn't even going to go that makes this
conversation part but it's like there's
a difference between principles and
living by the principle of the thing and
it being a reality Mikey's my brother in
Christ he's not my blood brother and we
go you know in our lives in that way
right that's how I would answer the
question I wouldn't go through a bunch
of different balloons what's up my
brother you know like you're still not
blood but you it's really like that the
bigger issue is that if it is incest
then he's just made God the author of
incest
and now you're questioning God on a
whole different level you know and
saying why would you want to obey
somebody like that or you know who is
that kind of person to set up rules
or laws for us to live by if they're
doing these things that we wouldn't even
you know condone so it's really getting
at a much deeper theological issue and
um
number one
um Brad I wanted some clarity because
you said that
in the beginning there was a larger
genetic pool but that was just two
people and I would say now wouldn't the
genetic pool wouldn't that be a less
genetic pull and then now it would be
larger because now you have ancestry to
go by and then also
what's the difference because there's
two we still came from two people
like making us brothers and sisters
technically we came from two people and
then we came from two people again
because it all traces down to the two
right it all traces them but as as you
connect these different because you know
how how
boy this is gonna get awkward fast you
know how the egg and the sperm when they
come together and they have this uh this
genetic thing that intertwines together
and you make a different person right
but during that that time
manipulations can happen right and when
you make some when that's just a little
more diluted I guess you can say than
the last person the beginning of the
genetic pool was perfect but now we are
getting to a point where as we we have
sinned and we do different things or we
are our diet affects our genetics our um
our our sin affects our genetics we pass
these traits on from one generation to
another in it and it dilutes the gene
pool
I I think I wanted to reflect more on
what he was saying about like how
he treats women and it's like he he's
following biblical principles now and
now he's he feels like he's getting
blessed and returned for it like
treating women with respect no matter
where they're at you know he went to
this
adult film star who's doing drugs which
most people are either going to judge
her or try to get with a hook up with
her or something and he just talked to
her like she's a person like you don't
have to do these things like there's a
better way you know he's trying to
witness to her I do I he said something
though he said that the sin would always
be there you're just going to look at it
from a different perspective do you
agree with that statement
is he talking about it from a general
sense or a personal sense like because
it sounded like he was talking like he
was struggling with a certain sin Mike
Gail uses that you as an example because
you're the story that came to mind
alcohol didn't vanish because Mikey made
the decision to not drink anymore so I
think that's what he's meaning by the
girls are everywhere lust is everywhere
but I don't look at them Temptation yeah
right you know you can use that I don't
know that yeah sin was maybe the best
word to use but really Temptation okay
is every time we bring up God like this
you see what I'm saying that that makes
them uncomfortable he will see and make
someone else here it's just asking
questions it makes him uncomfortable I
think I think it does
are you siblings
no I mean sometimes we just make jokes
in awkward situations like I mean I do
the same thing like whenever I'm feeling
like I can't stop I don't do what you do
I just I gotta bounce
you know this is your podcast so I love
that he's calling him out on that he's
like look we're talking about the Bible
and that's making you uncomfortable and
you gotta crack jokes and you know make
me look bad or whatever but hey I can
just tell that you're uncomfortable and
like his true colors are showing it's
like he's really not
making any kind of Point that's
debunking what the guy is saying he's
just like making fun of him really
humorous yeah four million people that's
how many subscribers he has I looked it
up just now four million people so at
least on this channel I think it's more
he's got multiple channels on this main
Channel things like 23. so which one is
Paul
oh the one with the blonde hair yeah oh
the one who was making a joke yeah yeah
okay
so we're here turning into a Sunday
school lesson so I don't blame you hey
why do you do a Saturday Saturday
Sabbath I gotta ask just I mean we could
do it after the bit is it you follow the
Jewish uh because I do that too I
actually really want to go to uh
Jerusalem but like yeah I do too bro
they and stuff you know seven days are
not work all that jazz
wow like a powerful Point like that I'd
like to see the rest of that I know
what's the rest of that video
so what do you guys think I mean he said
why do you so he said we turn into a
Sunday school lesson but then it's like
oh whoa that makes me it reminds me why
do you keep the Sabbath because I do too
both those guys kept the Sabbath both
these guys are on the show saying we
should keep the Bible we should keep
what the Bible says we shouldn't eat
these things we shouldn't fornicate
and hey we should keep the seventh day
it's fascinating topic because there is
very little if nothing in scripture that
says keep Sunday as a holy day
so I find it very interesting because
that's I mean you can go to any church
any church and talk about you should not
lie you should not steal Abraham I mean
adultery you should not you should love
your God you know all this stuff but as
soon as you mention the fourth
Commandment people are like whoa whoa
whoa I'm saved by grace yeah
as if you know Grace allows you to sin
yeah it's called cheap Grace right
yeah did you have a question or
something no I was just going to say
that
that I'm fortunate that
um are
I I guess the culture of Christianity
that we have today is very like
um comfort based um and it's just kind
of like lifestyle based too yeah like
whatever the culture's doing I'm gonna
make the body fit that so that I can
live like the world yeah it's just it's
like whatever's comfortable to you
whatever it is it like caters to an
individual but also
um it's I don't know it's just a safe
Christianity there really is no
compromise there really is no obedience
there really is no everything is my
truth and I think it's really
unfortunate that it's boiled down to
that that's not Christianity no yeah
it's not Christianity relativism right
right and it's sad that it's seeping
into the church though because it's like
you know you can do what you want to do
I'm going to do what I want to do as
long as we don't hurt anybody or it's
just kind of like a play it safe kind of
thing but it's like nothing's being done
there's no conviction there's no change
it's just I'm gonna do me and you're
gonna do you I think it's sad on this
issue of the Sabbath like we we deal
with it in comments I I talk to people
all the time on social media and I've
had multiple Friends Ask me like what do
you think about this and and we we go
back and forth look at this is a
scripture like it was blessed and
hallowed on the seventh day before sin
existed before a Jew existed like God
blessed it and hallowed it he set it
apart and then when the fourth
Commandment comes along
it says remember this day the one that I
blessed at the beginning
but yet now people are like
that's legalism but I go to church every
Sunday well why do you go to church
every Sunday because it's it's kind of
like keeping the Sabbath it's still
every week I'm keeping this day and
that's kind of what they say they say
well I think we can keep any day well
why is it always Sunday why not just say
well we can keep any day might as well
do it God said what's fascinating about
that is
in Exodus 20 when God introduced The Ten
Commandments at Sinai
just before that in Exodus 16 he
introduced the Sabbath into their
community
before the Ten Commandments yeah yeah
and he hadn't introduced all the other
Commandments or anything else he
introduced this time period in Exodus
16. and he said because I want to see if
you'll walk in my laws walking my ways
or not and it was a test to them
you know would they obey God and now
it's not it's not viewed that way
I understand people's reasons for
worshiping on Sunday I've heard a lot of
that but you know kind of what Brad was
saying if you look like just even
statistically
there are
eight verses in the entire New Testament
that reference Sunday
and almost all of them say the first day
of the week
and five of those eight are the same
event they're all recorded in the gospel
just Jesus being resurrected
from the dead on that day and it's it's
reported on as a historical fact
the book of Acts if I remember right
records 13
accounts of Believers getting together
worshiping on the Sabbath
now
that's interesting because you have one
book in the New Testament that has more
references to the Sabbath
than all the New Testament combined on
this other
one day so the the emphasis
for such a high precedence
I don't think is there it doesn't speak
to me that it's it's there that it's so
important another one people try to work
in is in Revelation when John said I was
in the spirit on the Lord Lord's day but
that's not really defined
it's it's an assumption to say that it's
Sunday if anything you know there's a
text I think it's in Matthew that says
um
that Jesus is Lord of the Sabbath which
would make that the Lord's day yeah when
you look up the Lord's Day in the Bible
that's the only time it comes up and
like you said he's the lord of the
Sabbath also it says remember the
seventh day for it is the Sabbath of the
Lord thy God so if God has a day if the
Lord has a day it's the seventh day so I
think the scriptural evidence to
make Sunday
um become the Sabbath somehow is weak
no I agree and I think at you know to
what you said I think it was Exodus
what was Exodus 20 is that where the
commit cabinets are given yeah and then
Exodus 16 is where they're uh the South
introduced it's even introduced an exit
in Genesis 2 right when it says and God
blessed the seventh day and Sanctified
it because that in it he had rested from
all his work that God would create it
that God which God made so it was
instituted from the beginning before sin
that means all this stuff was instituted
before even
the temperature management so it wasn't
given to Jews God said it was given to
man Jesus said that in the New Testament
right and so it was it was definitely
for man it's the purpose of keeping this
day and you know we know that God if you
look at the Bible he's he's really
trying to restore things to the way they
were in Eden
that's right and it's clear from Isaiah
that the Sabbath is the day that we will
worship again the Bible says from one
new moon to the next and from one
Sabbath to the next All Flesh will come
and worship before me for all eternity
yeah so it's like you have the Sabbath
in the beginning you have the Sabbath in
the in the end it seems like why
wouldn't you have the Sabbath in the
middle right right along with many other
things the dispensationalist movement
it's kind of like that's what I find out
I'm like well the Bible says this and
like no that's for the Old Testament
Jews okay well Revelation says this no
that's for the tribulation Saints what
part of the Bible is for us today
literally like everything I say is
either that's for them in the future or
that's for them in the past but we live
in this age where we do whatever we want
and it doesn't matter and like I I find
it sad when people say that the Jesus
never reinforced the Sabbath in the New
Testament or whatever what's it Matthew
24. yeah well Matthew 24 he says pray
that your flight not be on the Sabbath
day this is when he's talking about the
future tribulation to come why would he
even mention the Sabbath if it's gone
right yeah and the Bible is very clear
that that you know it was going to be
that way that we were that we were going
to get to that point it says you know
all we like sheep have gone astray each
one has gone to his own way and the lord
has laid on him in the iniquity of us
all that's in Isaiah 53 and it it also
tells us that our our hearts are
deceitful and it tells us that every man
does what is right in his own eyes you
know it talks about that with uh during
the time of Israel speaking of the
condition
of man they just did what was right in
their own eyes human beings haven't
changed we still do what's right in our
own eyes one of the things interesting
like on the the food thing people will
be like our whole church is doing the
Daniel diet for 10 days we're eating
like this and it's like oh I do it every
day
legalized it's like wait a minute people
do this 10 day Daniel Fast because
they're like
I felt amazing but God moved in so many
ways wouldn't it be good to feel that
way all the time which is what Daniel
was doing yeah he was doing it forever
he just said test us for 10 days and
we'll prove to you that this is better
for all that works all the time yeah
what do you say about legalism it goes
back to what I said earlier that's
always the thing that's thrown in like
you can tell if someone's a legalist
just by what they're doing right it's
impossible to tell if someone's a
legalist just by what they're doing you
don't know their motives behind it one
of the things interesting is people go
to church every Sunday and they'll say
you know what it was Sunday why weren't
you at church like it's it's just like
well that's the day to go to church
you're hearing music and everything like
I I do this on a Sunday or whatever but
when you say the Sabbath people are like
that's legalistic that's bondage that to
me that's just like if your wife says
hey honey
why don't we set aside every Saturday
we're gonna we're gonna let the kids get
a babysitter you don't go to work and
let's spend date night together so we
can build our relationship stronger if
their husband responded you're not going
to put me under that legalistic garbage
how does that make God feel
in calling someone a legalist that means
that they're following the text but I
thought the text
they're saying that the text says
otherwise so doesn't that refute their
whole argument
saying that you're doing the right thing
if you do the right thing you're a
legalist if you do but I'm also saying
I'm doing the right thing that I'm
following the text by going to church on
Sunday well then you're not if I'm the
legalist so then the text is true that
it's Sabbath yeah I find it ironic that
people say well the day is just a day
but then when you post something like
happy Sabbath they're like oh are you
Jewish it's like well I thought the day
is the day why are you going to give me
a hard time if I keep this day the one
that God said it's like well a day
doesn't matter as long as it's not the
Saturday day so but how do you
um
I guess
what evidence do you have for some
people who think that the Sabbath is
Sunday because the Bible doesn't
actually literally say
stats her day is the Sabbath versus
Sunday and then you have like calendars
in Europe that start on Monday so then
it's like for them sad the Sabbath
really is on Sunday it's the seventh day
for them where that argument fails as if
you can't tell from evidence and history
and time what day is Saturday then you
can't tell from evidence in history in
time what day is Sunday yeah yeah
because the same people that'll say that
argument well we know we don't know what
day is what are you going to be there
for Easter Sunday that's the day you
Resurrected
wait a minute how do we know that but
also we've had the Jewish Nation Keep
Saturday for the entire
span of their entire thing so yeah I
mean you've had Israel keep the Sabbath
from the beginning you've had Jewish
Nation keep the Sabbath I mean and all
you have to do is just follow them and
say look they're keeping the Sabbath
that's the Sabbath day there have been
times in the calendar where the calendar
was changed but the seventh day of the
week one two three or five seven let's
never change it's always been Monday
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday Friday
Saturday the names have been changed at
times but it's always been a seventh day
a seventh day of the week the numbers
have changed a little bit but the day of
the week has always stayed the same as
well that can be confusing just to
clarify like if today's Monday the you
know what just say today's Monday
January the 1st and then there's a law
tomorrow that tomorrow is going to be
December 25th it doesn't change it's
tomorrow still Tuesday right yeah yeah
and to your point about the law or the
principle of the Sabbath being for all
people not this just the Jews going back
to history there were people nations in
Africa keeping the Sabbath that had no
contact with the Jews as well so in
history throughout mankind
it's the Sabbath has been kept a lot of
people what I what I find is a lot of
the mindset you might want to the goal
is to look back at the Bible and say
okay what does the Bible say to you but
a lot of people are so looking at this
and going how can everybody in my church
be wrong how come there's so many people
going to church on Sunday they it's
impossible that they can't be wrong
there's number one there's a lot of
people not reading their Bibles but
number two listen listen to what the
Pharisees used to say this is John 7 48
have any of the rulers or the Pharisees
believed in Jesus
how could so many people how could so
many people be wrong on this I mean if
if the religious leaders are doing it
surely it must be correct I mean this is
what they said in the in when Jesus died
they said how can all these people be
wrong Jesus surely isn't the Messiah
right I recommend watching from Babylon
to America by school for profits it
gives a whole history lesson but
basically this all started with Roman
Catholicism though well Pagan Rome which
became Roman Catholicism which basically
just said
Constantine was trying to kill all the
Christians but every time he killed one
ten more would pop up because they're
like wow that's the person that died for
the faith I want to join that
because it's real and then he found out
if you can't beat him join them type
thing so he's like okay you can worship
your God but it's going to be on the
venerable day of the sun when all the
shops must be closed and you see that
Pagan Temple over there with all those
Stone statue Idols yeah those are
actually Paul Peter John you know just
renaming statues and that's what
happened and so
when we came over here we just kind of
clung to some of those old traditions
which I think is what Revelation is
talking about the wine of Babylon the
doctrines of confusion you know that we
don't where there's so many Christian
denominations yet we have so many
different beliefs
but it can't all be right
well I think we made our Point yeah I
think it was a interesting video it was
an interesting video If you guys yeah I
know right holding it down I liked it if
you guys enjoyed this video If you think
somebody else would enjoy this video
please share it please give it a simple
and free thumbs up that really helps get
this video in the algorithm so other
people can see it if you want to support
this ministry you can do so on patreon
by doing that monthly we cannot do this
without you guys and if you want to get
something for your money check out
lightwear.shop a lot of cool Christian
t-shirts out there so that you can
really wear your witness and start a
conversation about things in the Bible
and it helps support us too we love you
and we thank you and we'll see you guys
next week
hey denique here have you ever asked any
of these questions like why does the Old
Testament and New Testament God seem so
different or what does the Bible have to
say about sex why do we have to wait for
sex until we're married or maybe who are
144 000 or why does it seem like God
doesn't answer my prayer when clearly he
says ask and it shall be given to you
Etc yeah I've had those questions too
that's why you should tune in every
single Wednesday to our brand new
podcast the Little Light Studios podcast
in which we seek to answer your most
challenging Bible questions make sure
you look us up and hit subscribe on
Spotify Apple podcasts or anywhere else
where you listen to your podcasts we'll
be there every Wednesday see you then
foreign
[Music]